les allemands redoutent une nouvelle
mise à l'isolément alors que le
déconfinement a débuté de manière
progressive depuis le 20 avril dernier
quelques localités ont décidé de freiner
la procédure
des mesures de confinement ont déjà été
rétablie par endroits une situation qui
n'est pas du goût de certains allemands
qui ont décidé d'exprimer leur
ras-le-bol comme ici à stuttgart où
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
réunies il évoque une atteinte aux
droits fondamentaux
le lieu de la manifestation de notre
manifestation générale
et de rappeler que les mesures prises
dans le cadre du corps des virus ont
fortement restreint les droits
fondamentaux et que c'est ce que la
majorité ici et les organisateurs
souhaitent que les droits fondamentaux
soient rétablies donc bien sûr ils sont
seulement restreint mais nous voulons
que ces restrictions se relever c'est en
principe le plan des mesures de
restrictions dont une partie de la
population ne veut plus entendre parler
je crois que je suis avec les autres qui
font des revendications qui voulons
retrouver nos vies et nous voulons que
l'action gouvernementale nous ramène
dans des eaux normale avec des décisions
clairement justifié sont pas basés sur
des spéculations des simulations et sur
la façon dont nous allons avancer dans
les semaines et les mois à venir et cela
doit commencer avec la fin de ce
confinement
les protestations ne respectent pas
toujours la distanciation physique
donnant lieu à certaines scènes agitée
la police a par exemple procédé à
certaines interpellations à berlin pour
l'heure une règle prédomine 1re
confinement si plus de 50 cas pour
100000 habitants sont détectés en une
semaine
outre-rhin les modalités d'isolement
n'ont toutefois jamais été aussi strict
qu'en france